there's still been no Security Council
meeting about the Trump middle-east plan
the US ambassador Kelly Kraft has not
briefed her colleagues but she did come
to speak to reporters outside the
chamber in the days to come that we'll
be able to work with the countries that
were very positive and hopefully have
more dialogue and I'm open to
conversation with Mansoor what is there
in this deal for the Palestinians to
like that doesn't this just reward
Israel for illegally taking Palestinian
land over many decades you know I think
I think what you say is a dialogue that
has become normal and we need to move
away from that dialogue because it's not
normal and we need to focus on the
Palestinian the children the future of a
Palestinian state
she says she's prepared to discuss the
plan with the Palestinian ambassador to
the UN but he made it clear to me it's a
meeting he won't be taking there is not
a single Palestinian official will meet
with palatable American officials now
after they submitted an earthquake the
essence of it the destruction of the
national aspirations of the Palestinian
people
that is the Palestinians and the United
Nations now Israel may declare its
sovereignty over settlements in the West
Bank sooner rather than later
secretary-general what's your message to
Israel on possibly annexing the
settlements it's very clear our
statement is very clear on that he
didn't answer so I put the question to
his spokesperson for our position last
week last month last year and today
remains the same is that according to
Security Council resolution 23 34
Israeli settlement activities or
flagrant violations under international
law I mean that's that's been our
position the focus now will be on
Palestinian diplomatic outreach at the
weekend President Mahmoud Abbas will
attend an emergency meeting of the Arab
League in Cairo just over a week later
he'll be at the African Union in Addis
Ababa and then on forever the 11th he'll
attend a meeting here of the UN Security
Council
James BAE's al-jazeera at the United
Nations